Nevertheless, let us continue and
see how else this theory
enables common sense reasoning.
So consider the sentence,
Ashok enjoy eating the frog.
So not just Ashok ate the frog,
Ashok enjoyed it.
How do we make sense of this term?
Once again, because the word eat, we may
have the primitive action for ingest.
Here is Ashok as the agent, frog as the
object, and this time we'll have under
the slot called result, which shows
what happens when Ashok eats the frog.
We will call this frame a state-change
frame, where there was some initial
state and some state at the end of this
particular action, the action of ingest.
So, here there is Ashok's mood,
which is becoming happy.
>> So Ashok, how would the agent
know that in this case,
the verb we're going to key on
first is eating instead of enjoyed?
Good point, David.
So we can imagine
a different action frame for
feel because of enjoy being a feel.
The agent as Ashok.
Ashok is the one holding the feeling,
and the object, or
the feeling that is being felt, is joy.
We can still have a frame for eating,
and we can relate those two frames.
So what specific interpretation an agent
will make this particular sentence
will depend on the precise rules that
we're going to put into this slot so
that the agent can make either this
interpretation or that interpretation.
We'll see another example of
this situation in just a minute.